体がちょっと温まっ
秋っぽくなったよね、この水が
これ、今ね
私にこういう温度が寒い
寒い
あったかいところ
寒い?
もうダメです
持ってきました
暑い方が得意なんでね
そうか
エビキは?
全然反対
パパだっけ?
厚刈りです
こないだおかしかったんだよ
大輝がね
うちにご飯食べてるときにね
パパがね
お友達と約束があって
出かけるときにね
パパがね
送ってきてあげるっていうからね
だから
ああでも
違う場所だからいいって言ったけど
パパがとてもね
熱心に送ってってあげるっていうから
乗ったらね
すごい遠回りになっちゃってね
すごい時間かかっちゃったって怒ってたよね
うん
これぐらいはあるけど
あははは
うーん
ねえ
なんか
あったでしょ
どっちでしょ
あった?
車の音でしょ
なんか開け閉めした音だってこと
そうそう
クラットさんに
馬に触れられる機会が
今年の1月あったのね
そうなんですね
そうですね
年に1回
いろんな人を呼んで
初乗り会っていうのをやるんです
お呼びしようかなって
ちょっと
うん
ねえ
お母さんちょっと
寒いからね
1月は
ねえ
1月誘われるけど
行きたくないの
寒いかい
寒いですよ
ああ
下が凍ってるんだもん
馬場が
うん
下柱
あっ
そうかそうか
1月だから
1月だからね
うーん
でもみんな初乗りだから
その年初めての乗馬する日だから
夏森で集まるから
うん
皆さんも誰
だいたい僕が主催なので
皆さんに声かけて
ちょっと人数少ないとあんまりね
せっかくやったのに
家族も呼び出されたりして
私はどこでやるんですか?
東福祉でやってる
市も
早稲田の馬場だ
ああそうなんです
はい
小平のあたりですか?
小平のあたり
ちょっと手前ですね
手前ぐらいですね